What do you mean? Whatever I want to >> That's That's what's
keeping me out of the studio.
>> What do you mean? All right. Veto. >> I got it.
>> What do you mean? You got >> Oh, boy. Oh, boy.
>> Yeah, but it's not okay cuz you're not going to do it.
You're not going to do any of these things that you say you're
going to do. Just like you sat in the >> people. Yeah.
You keep saying I don't get it. Like it's like it's a permission
slip to act like an but it's not. >> Just talk. Just talk
to me. And >> talking to you is a waste of time. >> You're
a brick wall, bro. The only reason to talk to you is to turn
it into content. There's no reason to talk to you outside of
the show. Do you not get >> You don't matter
about don't matter to you at all. You don't matter at all. The
things you care about don't matter at >> I got it. I got
it. >> Don't ever contact me again.
>> Really? For context, they've been recording the show
through Zoom or Discord or something for 2 months now. According
to Dick, it's because of his ear infection. Makes loud sounds
hurt.
But neither me nor Veto are buying it because he's been recording
episodes of the D show with a guest at a studio the entire time.
No problem. Oh, that is
very weird. What?
What? Massachusetts man people on YouTube are pretty and worried
about the YouTube ID stuff. It's a little justified though. What
are you talking about? >> And for 50, how do I get you
guys back in studio together? I don't know. Um,
>> I don't know. >> Inject my >> I don't know.
>> Inject my tempus tempanany muscle with Botox while I'm
sleeping. That's the next step. If the central nervous system
stuff doesn't work.
>> What? Sure. >> What? Sure. Okay. >> Whatever
you want to say. >> What do you mean whatever I want to
say? >> That's That's what's keeping me out of the studio.
>> All right.
>> What do you mean? All right. Veto. >> I got it.
What do you mean you got >> Oh boy. Oh boy.
>> Sounds good. >> Sounds good. You think you're
being kept out for some other reason? >> I don't know.
>> Obviously that you're passive aggressively saying >> I
mean
what's going on? I don't know. >> I told you what's going
on. Sound causes me a tremendous amount of pain. I don't know
where it's coming from. I don't know why. And I'm >> I've
definitely seen I've definitely seen screenshots of his regular
show, his show in studio with his with his co-host in studio.
>> I'm too loud. >> I mean, you're constantly loud.
Yeah, you're you're extremely loud. Yes,
>> it's I guess it's literally Veto, you're too annoying,
Veto, you're you're literally too annoying to be here. My other
my other guest Okay, my other guest will just talk normally.
Veto, you are too annoying. That's [__] up. So, could
I be less loud? >> Um, I don't think so. No. >> Okay.
Now,
in defense,
this should be an offshow contact uh conversation, right? This
should not be a conversation you have on the show. You don't
go, "Hey, you really don't like me, do you?" You don't do that
on the show. You is dick is being a dick. Okay? Is being an [__]
in fact. But you should not you should not go, "Hey man, it seems
like you don't really like me on the show." That's like that's
one of those things. Listen, not I'd never do it in this context
specifically, but uh I I sometimes put my foot in my mouth in
similar ways where I'll like ask something that shouldn't be
asked like publicly in public and put the other person on the
spot. And I know when I do it and I feel bad when I do it. And
Veto is Veto is just doing it right now. He's just like, "You
know what? Tell me right now. What's your problem with me? I
could be quiet. And Dick's like, "No, I don't think you could."
No, I don't think you're capable. >> Less loud. >> I
don't think so. No.
>> The silence.
The silence. >> That's fine. >> No. What? >> It
seems like it's not fine. >> It's not fine because you
started this by saying, "Okay, whatever."
Like you don't believe me. >> I I don't. >> You don't.
Okay. >> Uh well,
go [__] yourself. Ding-dong thug is for five. Oh,
by the way, Veto, what tiers of superkiller are eligible for
the refund? That guy's 3x cover pack with signature isn't eligible.
>> I don't know how you come back from that. That feels
like such a
Veto is a consmate professional. If he comes back from that,
keeps joking around. >> What is What's eligible for the
refund? >> The lunchbox. >> The lunchbox is elig
eligible for the
>> All right. Cameron for two. What era do we live in this
week? Veto, good question. Jav City for two. What's with all
the junk behind you? Veto Jackson. Mark Antonio for five. Whoops.
Uh, so sad that Joey Swoll quit so he won't get his fitness pandering
videos for a whole week. I know. It's so bad that he quit. Uh,
Jav City for two. Stop doing this. >> I mean, I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to be a dick. All right. I just don't know
what's going on. That's it. >> Um,
you don't know what's going on with >> A lot of things,
man. >> Such as I mean, you're fine with
Dude, I
Okay. Um, nothing. Never mind. >> That you don't believe
in like throwing >> I just want to talk I just want to
talk about it on the show, but I can't talk to you any other
way. So,
>> that's awkward. So, Veto is trying to reach out off
show and say, "Hey, Dick, we should talk about this. This feels
really weird. This feels really bizarre that I can't talk to
you. That you don't want to talk to me. That we uh we can't even
run the show normally. What are we doing? Right. But I can't
talk to you anywhere but publicly. You got to make yourself available
to your co-host. What's going on? >> Thing now. Don't just
like imply that you don't believe it or there's something else
going on. Say it. >> I don't know what's going on. >> Jab
City for two. Stop doing the he he laugh Veto. It hurts my ears.
Johnny Rocket for 10.
dude. The chatters the chatters constantly donate the with Veto
too. Like why would they say explicitly, Veto, you hurt my ears
with your laugh? Why? Why would they say that specifically, right?
They know precisely how to [__] with this guy. >> Confused
about what's going on with this >> You're messed up, dude.
>> What's to be confused? >> Messed up.
>> I don't know. Are you like, are you happy with the show?
>> Um, no. I think you're low energy as >> Okay.
So, what can I do to make the show like something you would enjoy
doing? Cuz it feels like you don't enjoy doing it with me. I
mean, I'm not I'm not going to like tell you how to act in a
way that I know. I'm not Look, >> dude, just be who you
are. And who you are, I think, is somebody I hate.
But I'm not telling you that like I can't like you. I'm just
telling you that who you are right now is something I hate. And
you know, but I'm not going to tell you who to be, okay? Just
what you're doing now. All of this, all of this is really up.
knew how to act in a way that >> I know I'm not >> caters
to like some imagined version of me that you have in your mind.
>> I'm just going to make you happy. I >> show up
with energy. That's it. Show up with energy. >> I feel
like I've I feel like I've been doing that and you're not happy
with me. I feel like I've had great energy on a number of episodes.
It's like things just keep deteriorating. So, I don't know what
to do anymore. >> Stop arguing online. >> Stop arguing
online. Show up with >> That's different. >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay, hold on. Stop arguing online. We'll say that.
I don't watch a lot of The Biggest Problem, okay? Not cuz it's
not a good show, but mostly it's just not content. Unless there's
something going on between Veto and I just not They do a very
similar idea, right? Cover news on the internet. So, I don't
cover it a lot, but I've heard D make that complaint on at least
two occasions. Hey, Veto, stop fighting so much on Twitter. Stop
fighting so much on Twitter. Stop fighting so much on Twitter.
Now, in Veto's defense, I believe the stuff he's fighting on
Twitter about is like people are coming to my house and recording
videos and it's weird,
right? But for him to go for him to go, just tell me what to
do. Just say that. Stop fighting on Twitter. Just say that.
He has said it a couple a couple times. I'm aware of he said
it. >> On a number of episodes, it's like things just keep
deteriorating. So, I don't know what to do anymore. >> Stop
arguing online.
>> Stop arguing online. Show up with >> That's different.
See, that's different. >> No, it's not different cuz it's
>> like there's you won't do it. Stop arguing online. Show
up with energy for the show. >> Instead of this like e
What do you mean stop arguing online? What do you >> Oh,
I'm sad.
I'm sad. Guys, >> stop going on Reddit and treating fans
like Stop going on Reddit and giving snarky, sarcastic answers
to people who want either either when to know when their comic
is coming out or when they're getting a refund, which you said
you would give them. >> Okay. No refunds unless you get
the lunchbox tier. I could refund that or if you mailed me uh
some there's somebody who I a couple people got a refund, but
other than that, unless you got the lunchbox tier, no refunds.
And uh
Okay, don't go on Reddit. Got it. >> No, I said stop arguing
online. >> What is What am I arguing about? What do you
mean? >> Is Is there meaningful progress being made in
the comic? I actually don't know. I see everybody talking about
Superkiller. I see everybody saying, "Where's Superkiller? Where
is it?" I God, Veto is like very funny. I like Veto. I just don't
understand what's going on here.
What are we doing? What's going on? I just explained it. Stop
giving snarky, sarcastic answers to people who are
money. Why? Why? >> You asked what you could do. I gave
you the answer. >> Okay. But I don't understand why this
bothers you. A guy >> because these
>> Okay. You want You want my read on this having watched
a grand total of like 5 hours of their show. I love their show,
by the way. I reference their show way more than I actually watch
it because I think they're both very funny. Okay. I think they
are a good duo together to do a show. I think they they've had
a problem, though. Okay. And and did try to fix that problem.
Thought, okay, Veto feels like I don't value him. Veto feels
like he's in an unsure place in the show. And so Veto had a very
similar issue last year, right? This is the same issue as last
year. Veto was fighting a lot of fans and and it was like kind
of was like, "Okay, I think this is coming from a self-conscious
place where you don't feel safe on the show. So I'm going to
give you half of the trademark and half of the show. You own
half of the show now, right?" So Dick has gone out of his way
done something that I feel like was way out of character was
he was actually sensitive to somebody else's needs and he went
out of his way to go and say hey here's half the show right here's
I want you to feel better here's half the show
and and now
they're in the same place again and doesn't seem like a particularly
sensitive guy I think he just had a kid so I'm guessing that
he's like I can't I can't do this again I can't like have this
same thing happen again and it's not really
should move Veto into his place to fix it this time.
But I think I think like gone out of his way to be sensitive
and and stuff in a way that he's not usually, right? And Veto's
back in the same spot again. The comic's still not out cuz I
think the comic last year was a big thing as well, right? I think
Riley and Mitt were were hitting on the comic. A lot of the fans
were hitting on the comic. Where's Superkiller? Where's Superkiller?
And now we're like six months, eight months, 10 months later
and it's like Veto, where's Superkiller? Veto, what's going on?
Veto, what are we doing? What is happening? Veto, you projecting
your personal life onto Yeah. I don't know. I really don't know
why,
man. It's a It's just a little odd is all. It's just a little
odd is all. Okay. Um, but we'll see. We'll see if they get there
cuz yeah, Veto's also not being very proactive in like solving
like just it feels like it just keeps deteriorating. It's not
like helpful. I can tell you wouldn't be helpful with uh >> you
could do I gave you the answer. >> Okay. But I don't understand
why this bothers you again >> because these people pay
hard earned money
for content.
>> To support to support us and unfortunately that includes
you but to support me and us. They give us money to consume a
comedy product and instead of growing the product you're there
arguing and turning away fans who pay for the show. That's what
you do. >> You find people who are paying you money and
you treat them like
>> Who am I giving who's paying money for the show? >> Veto.
Go read. Go read why people cancelled the Patreon. And it's I'm
sick of Veto. He knows what he's doing. I'll come back when he's
done doing this >> He knows. >> There's tons of people.
There's tons of >> I'm confused, dude. I don't understand
>> I don't know how else to say this to you. Stop treating
paying customers like you're not better than them. >> Which
paying customer I treat like
>> Okay, guys, sound off in the comments if Veto is an
assh to you. If you if he if you paid money to Veto for his [__]
comic or anything else,
>> I'm I'm sorry, but I have to scroll down now. Vito should
do an episode parked outside driveway.
I never saw Harry Potter. Also, explains Voldemort's entire motivation.
Wait, did that happen? Veto just wants to be friends with again
and remove Veto from every aspect of his life is only doing the
show for the fans. There will never be a podcast dynamic like
this ever again.
Oh, that's kind of brutal. Saddest part is actually when Dick
tells Veto, "I don't think you're a bad guy." Ah, hold on. Hold
on.
Oh, man. This is This is uh more dire than I thought it was.
There's a spoiler. I I scrolled up [__] to you. Post
it. Post about it. >> The comic's not the show. Okay. It
very much is. >> The way I deal with people who go, I'm
going to report you to Indiegogo.
It should have nothing to do with the show. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Indiegogo. That's I mean that's a that's one >> guy
said a guy Well, yeah. And you felt you wanted to tweet about
it. You go I can't believe Veto. This guy says he's going to
report him to Indiegogo and Veto was dismissive and rude to him.
Yeah. The guy said he's going to report me to Indiegogo. What
should I say? Oh my god. Oh my god. Please don't report me to
Indiegogo. So sad. >> You shouldn't say anything. >> That
that also Yeah, that should not be. Don't do that. Don't do that.
Veto, what are you doing? Come on, man. Oh, no. Don't report
me. I dude, you you know who your audience is. You know who they
are. These people are
these people have made it like their personal mission to break
veto at this point. And he is not sensitive to that at all. >> Why
does it bother you that I do? Like, why does it matter? It's
my life. I won't do it. Okay, now that you're explaining to me
that it really bothers you. Okay,
that's so Oh, boy. Oh, boy. How do How do you guys feel? Okay,
I know I know how people feel when this happens. How do you feel
when you've explained something to a close friend, a loved one,
a partner, anybody? Okay, you've explained something to them,
right? You've explained it. And
after you've gone into deep detail to explain this thing that
they do that annoys you or upsets you, they will like months
later or weeks later tell you, "Hey, now that you've explained
it to me, I won't do it anymore." That will
about to break his own eard drums. Okay.
Is about to start screaming, I think. Not literally, metaphorically
screaming. Okay. But it I it sucks because I like veto but I
have watched this show a handful of times including during their
last fight and made this exact same sentiment very clear. Don't
be an fans. These fans pay us their money. It pays me off when
instead of like putting positive effort into the show you spend
time fighting with fans cuz I obviously like the implication
is I obviously want to go off on fans too. But I don't because
I think I could anytime I want to go off on a fan I can just
make the show better, right? I could just spend a little more
time writing out some bit. I could spend a little more time researching
something. I could be a little more informed. I could make a
post on Twitter about something funny, right? I could make a
joke somewhere, right? You make a funny joke that gets, you know,
5,000 likes on Twitter and suddenly you got 20 viewers on the
stream, right? I think that's what that's probably where mindset
is and and I've heard him explain this to Veto and Veto is doing
it again and then saying he doesn't understand and it's oh you
>> but like I'm not policing. >> Yeah, but it's not
okay cuz you're not going to do it. you're not going to do any
of these things that you say you're gonna do. Just like you sat
in the
>> people on Twitter all the time. I get messages from
them and they go, you know, I've been a longtime fan of the show.
I can't believe they would block me. Do you think I tell them?
Oh, I'll talk to him. I can't believe you. You're a paying customer.
He's got to respect you more. I go, "Yeah, well." Oh, I feel
like is going to go, "Yeah, tell me if they're a paying customer.
I'll I'll of course I'll unblock them if they're a paying customer."
Uh-oh. I'm pretty sure Veto is just walking into that right now.
I don't control block list and take it up with him. I'm not policing
your internet behavior, but everything I do, you catalog it and
you pitch a fit about it. I don't get it. What's the >> Hey,
did I ask you how I could make your experience better? >> But
I don't >> Did I ask you how >> Never mind. Yeah,
but guess what? You want to do the show with me? It's I It's
me who doesn't want to do the show with you. I don't need I don't
need tips on how to make your experience better. Oh, I could
change my behavior to make your experience better. >> Yes
or no? >> Cool for you to >> Yes or no? Did I ask
you if I did I ask you what I could do to make your experience
better? >> Yeah. You're basically telling me that you have
a double standard. You're >> Yeah, you're goddamn right
I do. >> You're saying all this stuff that you do, if I
do it, it's really bad and I can't do it. But you're allowed
to do
>> You've been dismissive to fans. You've told people to
off. You've blocked people. My raging at fans is based in Gigachad.
Your raging at fans is gay and soy pilled. Okay, that's how it
is. Veto. I'm not policing it. I don't give a [__]
You know, like >> Yeah, but I'm not asking you what I can
do to make your experience better, am I? >> So, but you're
saying to make your experience better, don't act like you. And
I have a different >> Don't act like Right. Right. Right.
Don't act like me. Act different. Act different. I can do whatever
I want. I can do whatever I want and you can't. How's that? So,
I got to be
>> All right, man. I'm sorry. I'm >> No more No more
sarcastic
snarky comments. No more I'll give you a refund. Now, I won't.
No more of that. No more arguing on Twitter. No more arguing
on YouTube. No more arguing on Discord. None of that. That's
it. >> All right, man. Fine. >> What do you mean?
Are you going to do it or not? >> It's uh it's really going
to suck, but I'll do it. >> To not argue on Twitter, to
not argue on Reddit is really going to suck. >> It really
will. But if it will make you happy and make for a better show,
I'll do it. >> No, I said I all I said was stop arguing
on Twitter, show up with energy. That's >> Okay. If that's
going to make the show more fun for you and you enjoy your I
want you to have a good time, >> right? Uh the gentleman
sausage.
So, here's the thing.
Is a bully, okay? You can't respond like this. I don't think
you can respond like this. I don't think this works. This is
Veto's normal way of like doing things.
Why is he getting bullied? Um, somebody in chat can answer you,
Marma dude. But is not going to respond to this, right? Hey,
be nicer to me. Hey, I just want you to be nicer to me. I'm going
to be nice to you, so you be nice to me. And unfortunately, there
are a lot of people on the internet like this. You can once in
a while go to like people like and say, "Hey, I'm like I'm annoyed
by this. Please don't do it." Right? And they might respect that,
but if that's going to be your consistent way of engaging with
them, you just need to mock him, right? You just need to mock
him. Like if Veto had come to this conversation and said, "Al,
[__] off. You're a loser. You you block fans. You
[__] on fans all the time. Kill yourself." Like if
he engaged back that way,
then
you might even get a response. You very possibly could get a
response, right? Yeah. You had the you had the show for longer
than me, so some of the core fans like will support you in doing
it, but you're just as much of a baby as me on Twitter. Stop
pretending you're different and and stop being such a [__]
I'm coming to the [__] stream or I'm coming to the
studio next time. And if you're going to be a [__]
about it and not let me in, then we won't do a show. [__]
you. Right. If if Veto did that, he might I I feel like he could
get a different response or might literally end the show. I don't
One of the two. One of the two. I'm not sure I'd risk it if I
were veto. I think it's a pretty substantial paycheck. So >> for
five, you don't need to go to another country to find an unscrupulous
>> I mean, you're just telling me to I don't What do you
want? What do you want >> What are you still crying about?
>> I'm not crying. I just like >> Stop arguing on
Twitter with with people who pay for your comedy and your comics.
Stop acting like you're better than them and and do the show
with some energy. What's wrong with that? >> I think I've
done pretty good energy.
Today you showed up like a sack of >> Yeah. Well, you know
what? You guys are kind of beating it out of me. I've been >> Your
job is to show up and make jokes on a microphone. You drama queen.
Not everyone is here to plate your experience. It's the easiest
job in the world. You cry about it every week. >> I'm not
crying about it. >> You cry about it constantly. You cry
about my motivation. What's my motivation? I'm the talent. I
need to be catered to at all times. It's so >> I don't
have to be catered to. I just want like a basic uh level of respect.
You deserve less. Honestly, you deserve >> Well, then why
do you why do you want to do the show with a guy you don't
>> Because it it comes in waves. Sometimes you're great.
Other times you're >> So sometimes you sometimes you respect
>> No, I never respect
>> So sometimes you sometimes you respect >> No,
I never respect you. >> Sometimes you make [__]
comedy. >> What's the point of this? >> What do you
mean what's the point of this? It's funny sometimes except when
[__] like this is happening. >> What is like
this? I'm trying to understand what is happening. You haven't
communicated with me for like 2 months now. You tell me I we
can't email about the show anymore.
>> I'm just like we will never email again. Are you insane?
You send these psychotic like exgirlfriend emails about skitso
Shawn all the psychot what was psychotic all the time. What was
psychotic? Tell me what was I psychotic about the email. Any
email at all that has to do with your internet fights is psychotic.
>> It's not psychotic. I literally just said, "Hey, uh,
here's the thing I don't want to talk about on the show." You've
had things you don't want to talk about. >> I'm canceling
Hackamania. You remember that one? >> Totally okay with
them. >> You remember that one? I'm canceling Hackam. I'm
not doing Hackamania.
>> That being an email. >> That was a voice. Yeah.
I wish it was an email. I would have posted it. It was a phone
call. You remember that? >> I have no ability to cancel
Hackamania. I called. said you weren't coming. Do you remember
that?
>> Okay. Psychotic. I'm not going to Hackamania cuz Riley's
making fun of me. >> I don't think it's psychotic. I just
>> totally stupid and psychotic. It is. Listen to me. What
you did during Hackamania
was stupid. >> Are you listening to me? Are you listening
to me? What you did What you did canceling Hackamania because
of Riley was stupid. Yes or no? >> Cancel. I did not cancel
uh Hackamania. I have no idea what that is. Hold on. Hackamania.
I'm not a I'm not a biggest problem enjoyer as much. So, Hackamania.
I thought this was the this was the con where they had um
Oh, they had Rakita, right? Rakita was here. Hakamania. It's
like a comedy conference or something, right? Lineup. Nobody
likes onions. Biggest problem. I think this is where they had
I think Rakita was at one of these things. It's just like a couple
of their friends who podcast or something, right? It's a gay
dabble verse thing. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Hey, it's just
some con they did. >> You called me and canceled Hackamania.
Why did I get tech Why did I get texts from Patrick Melton and
Carl all week about you canceling Hackamania? >> That's
crazy cuz I didn't cancel Hackamania. I said a million times
I'm going and I'm going to be there. So if >> What did
you say when you called me? >> I said, "Hey, I don't want
to go." And >> you said I'm not going. >> And then
what 10 minutes later I called you back and I said, "You know
what? I talked to Melton. I'm going to go." And I don't know
why I freaked out. >> No, that is not what happened. >> That's
absolutely what happened. I talked about not what happened. >> I
called you back. >> No, you did not. >> Oh, I must
have texted you back. >> I don't know. You're blocked.
There are there we had long conversations about who was going
to fill in for you. Can I do a show by myself? All this >> What
are you talking about? I talked to Melton 2 seconds after I talked
to you and he said, "Hey, uh, don't worry about it." I said,
"Okay." And then you had long conversations about who was going
to replace me at Hackamania. This is the first I'm hearing of
this. >> It's I mean it must be so confusing for you, man.
>> It is very confusing >> to go through these like
to go through life and have people act in wild ways and not want
to talk to you anymore. >> It must be so confusing. >> It
really is. I'm baffled. We got a great show. >> Hack the
movies. Hey, I just want to thank you for being a good friend
who always responds to my messages right away and privately.
Yeah. Matteo Roberto five rip Chuck Man for teacher for five.
That voted up song is the best song I've heard in my entire life.
I agree. Jay Cresino for five. Veto's crashing out on Reddit
today. I know. Cameron for two. Cat voice. Cat very professional.
Oink oink oink. Pigeon s for five. Eat Veto's cat first. Spider
eternal for two. The big the cat baby talk is cringe. Stop that
ship. Veto. Freddy Woods for five. Biggest problem. Others people's
pets. Cameron for two. Veto does his part. He always brings the
pretzels. Uh 4x4 plus for two. Veto nudes a lower quality camera
disgusting drunken atheist studio for two review naked gun
hilarious pigeon s for two uh Hulk Hogan >> I I get the
feeling that they're not done okay the said just revealed to
veto that hey I kept looking for replacements for you at this
uh at this festival we did I get a feeling it's not done give
me two seconds I just need to grab another drink h Bruce for
two thoughts on happy Gilmore oh my god a lot But I can't get
into it now. Spider Eternal for two. Cartman has something to
say to people like Kyle. Um
Mick
Mick Lights for five. I remember when Super Jail pulled off baby
on baby violence. That was a good episode. That was a good episode.
Strategy for five. Imagine watching a suspenseful Korean zombie
drama. But right when the main guy's about to die, Chuck. Wait,
is that a baby? Nobody wants that truth. Drunken Atheist Studio
for five. A scene from Baby's Day Out was shot behind my apartment
building in what used to be an abandoned Ovaltine chocolate milk
factory. Solid Chicago flick. I love that flick. Antagonist Vision
for two. Veto, please, for the love of God, wash your glasses.
Jav City for two. You already told this Red Lobster drink story,
Veto. Beach hook for 20. 20 is way too much for alcohol. Fishnuts
for five. Are you dating Dirk or something, man? Why are you
taking him on dates? I'm not British for five. I'm just glad
that my best friend Veto is having a good time. Strategy for
five, unlisted prices was a 2023 problem. Veto veto owes us another
problem. Drunk is an atheist studio for two. I found out there
are no need to watch more. Very much looking forward to it. Maybe
you can do a movie night. >> MF and a blue MF. Uh Oakley
for five. Think about how fast the Holocaust would have been
on a highspeed rail veto. Choo choo. Last stop to die out. Good
problem, Richard. Thank you. Salt Merchant for two. Engineers
swear an orth oath to uphold trains. >> An oi for two.
I should not be listening to super brain. I agree. You finish
your comic. Fishnuts for five V. I suppose Oh, somebody said
only 20,000 subs on YouTube. They do not have a lot of subs on
YouTube. They run almost entirely off of Patreon. Like their
Patreon is big. You go over to their Patreon. I think they have
like
15 135,000 in revenue or something at least. They've got like
a huge Patreon audience. It's crazy. Uh
9 thou Oh Jesus. 9,000. I thought it was more than this. I could
have sworn it was way more than this. Hold on.
hold on. What? Wait wait wait. Biggest problem. Let's see. Let's
see how big they are. Biggest problem in the universe. Veto.
No. The show is like massive. Is way bigger. Yes. But I thought
biggest problem had like 12 13k. So they they went up to 10K,
then they went up to 11K, almost 12K, and then they've been down
to 9K. So it's really not that bad. Like been consistent growth.
They had this big So this I think was the the original veto blow
up, right? Was about almost a year ago. Almost exactly a year
ago was like they were having this fall-off and then they boom
explode upwards. They had a little bit upwards and now they're
having a whole falloff again. We'll see if they can grow off
of this. They're a top 50, I think, super chat rev channel. Okay.
All right. That's still not bad, right? They're still doing pretty
good. I just thought it was a little bore. >> Memory of
the crypto comic, but that's for the rem that's for the reminder.
Thanks for the reminder. A real crumb comics experience. Okie
for two. Veto. Detective Gunnar to protect and perve. Trio Doug
for two. Veto. You can't criticize men's art after this.
Mr. Tattoo. Charlie for two. Chris Chant called. He wants his
drawing back. Ben Smurd for five. Eric July actually finishes
and releases comics. And his art is better. All right, let's
see what else. his art. I don't think Eric can
let's get So, Sean
>> yeah, I still think after these super chats, there's
going to be more here.
Eric, third Christmas with no super killer under the tree from
Diamond G. Bumbo for
>> Dick's like waiting for more super chats coming in,
right? Hey, he's waiting for more super chats to come in. Sh.
>> Why do all the females veto draws have hips smaller
than their shoulders? Ballistic arm bars for five. Highspeed
trains. Give me rocket planes like the man from the high castle.
Uh LJ Clberino for two. Happy beer day. Happy beer day. LJ J
Dragon for five. How high does the Patreon have to get to get
Veto back in the studio protected by drum shields? Uh
I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know why hyperacusis happens. Um, it's very complicated.
>> Can I Why would this even be a factor if he's got noise
cancelling headphones,
right? I assume he's got noise cancelling headphones and like
you you could just set like a like a noise gate, right? Or not
a noise gate, you could set a compressor on your headphones.
Like the input to your headphones could just have a compression
on it that keeps Veto's volume low.
Like I this actually this seems like a totally I will say on
part this has to be like an entirely manufactured problem, right?
It does not actually have to be a problem at all. It's like made
up. It's entirely made up. It feels like you can't stand them.
Maybe. And >> Oh, sorry. Not maybe. No, that has to be.
That has to be what it is. Not maybe. That has to be what it
is because the sound problem is made up. The sound problem is
invented. I think it's intended to be an obvious lie. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. It is like obviously a 100% just a lie. Doesn't
make any sense. >> It's um
it's in mostly a central nervous system essential auditory processing
problem. So I don't know. >> How about we build a little
box with like plexiglass and I'll just be in >> We put
it underground then we can put you in it.
>> I'll go in your pit. >> Great guy. Gabe for two.
Veto veto. Cameron for two. Skitso Sean gave you 4K in the last
month. Thank you Skitso Sean. Skitso on TV for five. I've given
you over $4,000 and you treat me like a terrorist. Bender for
five. Stop picking fights. Stop calling Dick's wife to defend
you. No [__] [__] man. Calling my wife.
>> Calling her to defend me. What are you >> calling
my wife? >> Wait, what? Wait, what? >> If at all
was a big [__] problem for
>> that
is not good. Okay, what? Why? Why did that >> Well, let's
talk about it. >> Yeah, kill yourself. That's what I have
to say about it. [__] problem. >> Why don't
you just talk to me about these problems? >> Because you
are a you don't ever change. >> Dude, what? Because yourself
>> now thing you don't listen and you everything you say
is a way to keep people talking. >> Man, I think I try
to understand what the problems are and I try to adjust my behavior
to make them better. But let's be clear. >> Next time you
have next time you have any kind of relationship with a man,
don't ever call their wife. How about >> That's That is
That is uh That is pretty >> Okay. I don't get it. I assumed
that you guys were at home. >> This is why you're because
you don't you just don't listen. >> Oh, I don't get it.
>> I'm trying to Okay, hold on. So, what happened is what
it sounds like is called Sorry, Veto called a landline. Does
have a landline. I thought you guys were at home. You like tried
calling a landline and his wife picked up and then he decided
to to still talk about it with the wife. That seems a little
weird. Explain to you why I would do it. Do you think I care?
>> No one cares. I don't give a [__] why you
would do it. Do you think I don't give a
why you would do it? I don't give a why you would do it. I don't
>> [__] I so badly want to take Veto's side.
I like Veto. Veto. Veto is a cool guy. I so badly want to take
his side, but I can't I can't take his Dude, that's just such
an obvious line. Do not do not talk to his wife about him when
you're having like an argument. That's crazy. That's wild. He's
not a cool guy. Ah, he's okay. Do you think I like Veto? Veto
come on the show. >> No one cares. I don't give a
why you would do it. I don't give a why you would do it. >> Don't
ever do it. >> I wanted to know where you were. I would
assume the person who lives with you would know where you are.
Veto, you bothering people with >> Why is it bothering?
>> Because it's taking time.
>> Okay. Okay,
that's maybe a little more forgivable is like, "Hey, is good.
I can't I can't seem to reach him." Now, the problem for Veto
is he'd have to he'd have to actually make us believe that was
having a hard time reaching him, right? Or sorry, Vito was having
a like that Dick wasn't intentionally avoiding him. I have a
feeling that Veto was trying to reach Dick and Dick was probably
still tweeting like a hundred times a day, right? Like it wasn't
like Dick was it wasn't like Dick was accidentally missing Veto's
call or hurt. Like you can see that he's on his phone. He's like
interacting with the internet and ignoring you, right?
So if if Veto is like calling his wife and being like, "Oh, I
don't know where Dick is. I just want to make sure." Yeah, you
can't really get away with that one, can >> You are not
worth the time it takes to engage with you. Then don't engage
with me but just tell me >> you are blocked on everything
because you are a time suck. Are you listening to me? >> Your
constant need of validation is a total waste of time. >> Okay.
This is the first time you have said veto it's too much time.
So now that I've heard it got it. I understand it's too much
time. You got other stuff going on. And I've said to you, hey,
if there's anything I can do to be less of a burden to me Stop
say that. >> I said I said it so many. >> I feel
like Oh, no. I feel like that's another thing that said is just
stop text. Don't text me about your problems. I'm not your dad.
Don't text me about your problems. I don't want to know. I'm
not you. I don't want to know about your problems at all. Right.
Do not tell me your problems. Don't text me with your problems.
Text me with cool ideas for the show. You want to text me with
a cool idea for the show? I'm all yours. You got a cool idea
for an episode, you want to do this topic, let's [__]
do it. You want to text me and say, "Well, I really don't like
it when someone else does this. Kill yourself. Get away from
me." Right? Now, I don't I wouldn't I don't approach like friendships
that way, but I totally understand. Dick is somebody who's like
running two podcasts, right? He makes a lot of his money from
podcasts. He's pretty much like retired. He's got all his money
and he just had a new kid, right? He just has a kid. He's got
his his wife and and his family. He probably wants to minimize
distraction, right? I'm guessing that he, you know, last year
it sounded like he was ready to just drop one of the shows entirely.
If he's ready to just drop one of the shows entirely, then yeah,
I feel like um
man, I do feel like Veto's got to be careful. Okay, Veto's got
to be really careful.
Back it up just a little bit here. Uh hello. >> Many times
I said don't text me. Don't ever text me about >> what's
My keyboard just went out. Hold on. Hold on. Need to [__]
one second. I need to go get a cable or something. I'm backing
it up. I'm backing it up just a little bit. I need to go grab
a cable for my keyboard. It's too much time. So, now that I've
heard it, got it. I understand. It's too much time. You got other
stuff going on. And I've said to you, hey, if there's anything
I can do to be less >> texting me,
>> stop say that. >> I said I said it so many times.
I said, "Don't text me. Don't ever text me about your internet
fights. Never. Never. >> Anytime I've texted you, I've
tried to text because it's something about the show." Okay. But
>> this No, no. See, this is why you This is why because
>> you do you text me about and say it's the show. >> It's
you. >> No, it's not to me. >> I don't give a what
you think is not
Here's what you don't totally [__] You're saying
you're saying veto this is really important to me and I'm going
I got it and even if I don't understand I'm going to respect
it and I say to you this is really important to me and you go
you're and I don't respect that at all and that's the difference.
>> No, the the difference is
you don't >> I care about don't matter to you at all. You
don't matter at all. The things you care about don't matter at
all. >> I got it. I got Don't ever contact me
>> Jesus Christ. >> Anything that matters to me.
You don't care about anything not matters to you. You nothing
matters to you. You doesn't matter to you. >> Who's trying
to understand what matters to you and what's important to you
and what you need and what boundaries you need established. And
I'm going out of my way to establish the boundaries. You're blocked
on everything. I don't need you to I don't need to work with
you to establish boundaries. You're blocked. I feel attack. I
found I feel attacked in the Discord. bother. >> Dude,
I feel like uh Veto needs to start pointing out. So, this sound
issue is just totally made up, right? You just you're a passive
aggressive [__] and you totally made up the sound
issue, right? Admit that you totally made up this sound issue.
You don't think it's actually an issue. You just don't want me
in the studio. Don't be a passive aggressive. Actually, say what
you you should start pointing out some of stuff. Okay. If anything,
to just salvage a little clout with the audience. >> Merchant
for two. First live show I've caught and this is how it ends.
Uh J bro, Dak for five. Superkiller became part of the show.
Yeah, I know. vetoed
>> it's not part of the show. >> It is obviously
part of the show. No, nobody would have supported you. >> You
decided to make it a huge part of the show. And I don't think
you can get upset later when it's a part of the >> And
guess what? I can I can get upset whenever I want. >> That's
where the money comes from, Veto.
That's where the money comes from.
>> I'll get upset about whatever the I want. I'm not telling
you not to be upset about it, but I'm saying if it's actually
making you upset, don't actually be upset.
>> What do you mean don't actually be
>> Are you treating people who backed you
>> How you are? Because you're a to them. Anytime somebody
asks about their comic that they paid for, you're a to them.
>> No, I'm not. If you say >> Yes, you are. You 100%
[__] >> If you go, "Hey, bro." If you go, "Hey,
man. Uh, how's the how's the status of the comic going? I always
respond. I go, well, here's where here's what we're doing. If
you go if you go, hey, fat boy, where's my >> comic? I
I might go you. >> Obviously, these are obvious lies. This
is like this is the way you lie. This is the way you lie. It's
like, oh, I can't even believe you'd say that. Yeah. >> Who
who asked very Who asked in a nice genuine way, hey, Veto, I'm
a fan of the comic. When's it coming out? You know, I want And
I said, oh, [__] you. You know, Nick didn't say that.
>> When does that ever happen? >> Tons of people
uh
that's totally
vision for 10 veto. You black
and you refuse to post more pictures of your cats when I paid
hard earned money for you, bro. Jacob
show. It's not even a comic. Yeah, nobody gives a [__]
about the comic. It was about supporting you. Okay, then don't
>> I mean that's good news because the comic [__]
sucks. Like the jokes aren't funny. It's dated.
The stories like piece together.
It's it's total dog [__] A Carl for five just released
the comic. Drink a monster before the show. Mute Twitter tards
and be funny. You're hilarious when you want to be veto. Yeah,
that's true. Bruce for five. I'm veto. I'm fat and gay. And I
love Israel and I think that Sydney Sweeney is a Also, I'm gay
and I'm veto. Spider Eternal for five.
Dude, apparently the Sydney Sweeney went even further. People
are like unloading on Sydney Sweeney. I >> Stop acting
like a child. Are you so clueless that you can't see the crushing
level of stress you put on Richard and anyone that works with
you? Jad
Dragon for two. I Yeah, you keep saying I don't get it like it's
>> like it's a permission slip to act like an but it's
not. >> Just talk just talk to me and >> talking
to you is a waste of time. >> You're a brick wall, bro.
The only reason to talk to you is to turn it into content. There's
no reason to talk to you outside of the show. Do you not get
>> So, what's the show? >> This. Bring in problems.
Have high energy. Stop arguing on Twitter. That's >> This
is just so bizarre, man. Like, >> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're
not getting your way on this one, bro. I'm not talking to you.
>> What is getting my way? Okay, that's >> going
like having having extended phone calls with you, going to dinner
with you to hash things out. I'm not doing any of that [__]
[__] Kristen Dorf, too. I paid for this because it
is a waste of
time. I paid for this super chat
for two. We like VTO. Veto Davidson for 20. Veto is twice the
size of Matt and has stuck around for twice episodes. Get your
PPP. Get PPP as your next co-host and Biggest 3.0 might reach.
>> Dude, PPP might go actually like super hard, dude. That
might PP
P might go that that might go hard, dude. That could actually
be really funny. Shut the [__] up for two seconds.
>> Edgars pigeon cell for five typical a-hole asks for
a solution and then disregards everything you say. Yeah, exactly.
It's infuriating. Just like the just like the talking is all
they want to do. They want to wear you down. >> Well, PvP
and hate each other. Never >> Makes up their their solution
which is always deal with them more. >> Cameron for two.
Pig and mud. Oink. Pig and mud. Piggy and mud. Cameron for five.
Just remember Veto, you're on this show because he couldn't get
Boogie. Boogie would not be nearly as good as I am. And I think
we all know that cuz uh somebody's got to bring the comedy. That's
it. Not just the sad, pathetic
Look, I don't understand because we got a great show. We should
be very happy about what a great show we have, >> right?
Are you Are you I don't get it, man. This should be a positive
experience for both of us. And it seems like it's not like you
like dealing with me is too much of a headache. >> Well,
not anymore. I blocked you. It's not. The headache is gone. >> I
don't have to deal with your online fights anymore. It's perfect.
>> So, that's that's The problem is my online fights. >> Well,
the problem is >> I want to get it crystal clear. I waste
your time. Yes. >> Uh yeah, I don't want to hear about
your online fights. I don't ever want to hear about them. Okay,
I got it. You don't want to hear about my online fights and you
don't want me to waste your time. >> No, online fights.
>> And that that's the one thing
is there's got to be more >> to No, it's just online fights.
It's online fights uh that you constantly make me deal with and
I don't want to deal with them. It's a waste of time. >> Okay.
Again, sure. >> What do you mean? Sure. It's a very What
I'm explaining to you is a very is a very very simple.
You pick fights with people, you get blown out and lose, and
then you cry to me and want me to ban fans from the show because
you lost an argument with them. >> I don't think that's
actually accurate at all, but is twisting the knife here. I don't
I don't think Veto like loses all these fights or anything. I
think the sad thing is is like Veto is basically like stop Well,
from what I've seen on Twitter a couple times, a lot of times
it's like Vito's like, "These people shouldn't be coming in my
house." And they're like, "Well, now I'm coming to your house."
Like some other random dude. Now I'm coming to your house. Actually,
that's it's not really fights that are like you can have a winner
and loser. It's the the issue to me is not that. And I get everybody
in chat saying, "No, no, Veto does lose." No, I don't think that's
it. I think Veto picks fights that he can't possibly win. If
you pick fights with schizophrenics constantly who have nothing
better to do than to [__] around with you, than to
just [__] with you. That's all they want to do. Then
you are going to have issues, right? You there is no winning
there. You can't pick fights with tons of skits and then win.
They don't have anything better to do. They'll come to your house.
They'll [__] with you in any way they can. And that
was Dick's point last time. I think that's point now. But he's
he's just like um I think he's tired of like giving Veto even
like a tiny tiny little bit of like charity over stuff. He's
just like, "Yeah,
out of here." Right. Yeah. >> That's what you do every
couple of
>> Okay. I don't want you to ban What does banning fans
from the show mean? What do you mean
that I don't want to talk about a guy who's coming to my house?
because I think that's a pathetic waste of my time and I don't
don't want to give I don't give promotion to people who go, "Oh,
what if I show up to Veto's house and [__] with him?"
I don't go [__] show time. >> Why'd you wear
a blueie shirt then?
>> You know what? I was I had it on at the time and I said,
"If I'm going to be on camera cuz I can't stop this guy from
filming, I might as well wear something >> Okay. So, you
did make content with him, >> I guess. So, and you know
what? Yes. You don't always think everything through. >> Yeah,
you do. >> You think I thought that through like really
long and hard and I said, "Oh, well, maybe I'm into it." >> I
think you thought it through. >> I think I said if I'm
going to be on camera and there's nothing I can do about it,
even if I don't want to be on camera, I don't know. Put on a
funny shirt. It >> Yeah. So, you're making comedy with
the >> I mean, do you think Boogie goes and goes, "Maybe
I should have." You just He really did just explain that, hey,
if this guy's here, I guess I'm going to put on a funny shirt
and go out and confront him. >> Born something different
instead of that Tomb Raider shirt. >> The whole point is,
you know, you're going to be on camera. How do you want to come
off? And I said, >> well, you're not on camera if you're
inside your house, are you? >> Okay, so maybe in the future
I won't come outside. I decided to come outside. >> Yeah,
cuz you're making comedy content with Skizo. >> I don't
want I don't want to make I'm not I'm not. >> Yes, you
are. You're making comedy content with These are your comedy
These are your comedy partners that you're making comedy content
with. >> Well, I'm hear >> I'm ending all comedy
partnerships. >> Yeah, you said that. You've said that
before, but you're always arguing with them in Discord. Blah
blah blah blah >> I don't want to hear about it anymore.
>> Shut Hold on. I have completely blocked all these people
on Discord. I'm not interacting with them at all. >> How
many times have you done that or said you've done it and then
not done >> This is the first time I've done it. >> look
at that smile. Look. >> Uhhuh. It's the first time Vo >> is
to not uh
>> the the issue here is for he like he did all the words
things already, right? I think and man, my impression is went
out of his way in a way he probably hasn't for almost anybody
to make Veto more comfortable in the show and it didn't do anything.
And probably sitting here like, "Yeah, I've I am cutting I'm
cutting my losses everywhere. He's blocked on everything. I don't
want to interact with this guy anymore." Right? It's over. It's
done.
That >> have to hear about whatever. Okay. >> I can
do it. >> Done. It's done. It's already done. What are
you talking about? I can do it. You're forced to do it cuz you're
blocked. You don't have a choice. >> I feel like we got
a great show and I feel like we'd have a better show. >> Show
up with more energy. Show up with more energy. Stop being such
a sad sack every show.
>> Veto Gwaldi, why do you wear a bluey shirt when you
are unmarried, childless, and bald? This is uh this is null.
I really think I really thought about putting on a different
shirt, but I said, "Nah, give him something to talk about." Nah,
give him something to talk about. Uhhuh. I kind of wish
do we really
I don't like Listen, don't lean into these jokes, okay? These
jokes aren't good to lean into. Don't lean into them. It's a
mistake to lean into these jokes, all right? It's a mistake.
It is. Don't do it. Jesus. Pick it up. More energy. Make stingers.
Make stingers. More energy. Get your comic out. That's it. All
this. Go talk to a tr Go talk to a woman or a guy who puts a
dress on.
>> Go talk to a tr a woman or a guy who puts a dress on.
Okay. >> Go talk to them about it. I don't
sick self-discipline there from Okay. Go talk to a
I need to know what's going on with the show. I don't understand
doing an extremely popular podcast where the two guys don't talk
or coordinate at all. I don't think it's making the show better.
>> Who cares?
>> I I feel like >> I don't I don't care. I don't
care. >> Right. So, this is what I don't understand. You
go, why would you be, you know, do a horrible thing to paying
fans? And I go, well, wouldn't the best thing to do to paying
fans to do the best possible show we can do? Oh, I mean that's
just like a question. Like I didn't say that. I said stop picking
fights with fans who pay you money. I didn't say whatever you
just said. That's garbage. >> Okay. And I shouldn't pick
fights with fans for what reason? >> Because they blow
you out and then you cry about it for a week. >> No. Come
on. Come on.
>> You basically said that. I don't know why he's being
like this. >> Always blown out by fans. >> Blown
me out. Wait, what are you How was I blown out by talking about
you argue. >> I'm not I'm not raped at all right now. >> If
you get blown out by Veto,
>> I have no idea what you're talking about. You guys live
in the same fight. You get in fights with Riley and then you're
like, I'm going to Mint. Oh, Jesus Christ. Yeah, that's a blowout,
bro. That's a big time blowout. >> Well, I don't get that
at all. Okay, maybe from you guys perspective.
I don't get it. >> I know. I know.
>> It's a huge blowout. I'm completely destroyed.
Uh,
I would like to do a great show. And I would like >> Have
some energy. Show up with some energy. Get your comic out. That's
it. No problem.
>> The comics's coming out. >> Yeah. Show up with
some energy then. Energy big time right at the front. Stop being
such a sad sack that needs to be dragged in every episode. Show
up with energy. I don't think that's been the case. I think I've
had good veto. Veto, lock the [__] in. Okay. Show
up with the energy. Be ready to go. I really feel
>> anytime I've watched the show from the beginning, Veto
has had energy. I wonder what's going on at the beginning. Maybe
we'll check we'll check out the intro maybe at some point here.
>> So, what's the point of talking to you then? Like, I
mean, you're doing everything perfectly. What's the point of
talking to you?
>> Cuz there's things I would like from >> I don't
give a about those. Look, look at me in my eyes. I don't give
a about what you want. Repeat it. Repeat it after me. I don't
give a
about what you >> So, we had like a really great show.
>> Veto's not repeating. Veto doesn't >> We had a
really great dynamic.
It was two guys against the world and now it's Veto and Veto
doesn't get what's going on. And it to me it feels like a miserable
show. I don't get it. Well, you became Eric July, bro. Like,
what do you want what do you want me to >> So, how did
And I Okay. How did I become Eric July? >> You have very
thin skin. >> I have very thin skin.
>> Okay. I don't think the defining quality of Eric July
is his thin skin. >> Okay. Well, what do you think it is?
>> Ineptitude, incompetence, inability to to make anything
of value. >> Uh Eric July's sensitive. Yeah. No, I would
say I would say Eric July's sensitivity from what I've seen.
Right. Somebody puts like a when did somebody put a piece of
p a piece of tape on like the door outside of his like some warehouse
he owned and he was like oh they're trying to kill me. It's definitely
the thin skin is like the reason he gets [__] with
so much. And it's it's a connecting thing with with Veto and
Eric July right like you are you are getting stuff connect you
are connecting these two things and you are being sensitive and
or you're connected in this way that it's very s you're very
sensitive
man. And I don't know. I I don't know how Veto lasted this long
being this sensitive on the on the biggest problem to be honest
with you. I >> so. How's your comic go? >> It just
seems it seems like um I just don't I don't don't get how they
had such a good good dynamic for so long when this is the case.
>> Incompetence, inability to to make anything of value.
>> So, how's your comic going? And why isn't it out? >> Why
isn't it out? >> Because I've been uh perfecting it. I've
been making it look in a way I want it to look. It's not out
because of
>> It's not out because of uh
I don't know if incompetence is the right word. I >> They
taped a $5 bill to the door of Eric July's comic warehouse. It
was Riley, the guy who veto Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I remember
this. >> Won't go into all the reasons for delays. Okay.
Oh, wait. Is this Is it Did it stop streaming? Uhoh.
Let's see.
Okay. No, it's still going. Yeah. The reason your comic's not
out is because of incompetence, right? >> Uh, this could
be a part of it. Dick has a lot of dad energy. Scares the bullies
away. People didn't People didn't realize that he wasn't going
to protect Veto until they kind of started poking at him. Maybe.
I bet he even protected Veto for a lot of the time until Veto
started getting sensitive over [__] Dick thought
was inconsequential, right? Like I feel like during the whole
when when KF was going hard on veto and calling him a I feel
like was like you shouldn't be you shouldn't be standing or dying
on this hill but he probably was like no he's not a obviously
he's not a right but then when it comes down to like people making
fun of him for his comic not being out like dude I don't I'm
not defending you on this like [__] off get the out
of here. Oh he left oh Veto left. Okay who wants to come in?
Oh he's back. All right there he's back. >> I got to Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. back.
>> He would have left there. Come on. >> I think
this is uh I think what's happening to go
honestly. >> What do you mean? What do you mean? >> How
did you think this conversation was going to go? Honestly, >> probably
about like this. I don't know. What do you I don't think I expected
anything more out of it. >> Like it's a valuable conversation.
>> These dudes have a falling out. They're in a perpetual
state of falling out. >> Well, let's see. Do you not do
you not think this has any value whatsoever? I >> no. I
don't I don't think it's funny. No, I don't think it has any
comedic value. No, >> I think sometimes Well, >> this
is good radio. Daniel Adams says, "Okay, Superkiller is the heartbound
of comics." Uh, Veto, who did ads for years about a comic
[__] read. >> These are super chats. Bender
for five. So, when the last show imploded, we got the genius
of mad Mike Hunt for five. Maddox and Dick was brought up at
the end of Sam Hyde show. I know. I got to watch that on my show.
Um, yeah. Okay.
Uh, Cro Cro Cronos for 5,000. Without veto, we would have another
TDS. One TDS is enough. Pineapple man for five. This episode
is textbook ESTP versus INFP.
Okay. Myers MyersBriggs analysis. You love to see it. >> Flashing
gay something. I just I just got linked to Shuon head tweet.
Jesus Christ. This is this is why I'm blocked by shoe head as
I called out a little bit of the anti-semitism. I don't think
this is a joke. I don't think this is a
I'm a single issue voter and that single issue is did not touch
the wall. That means she's a Biden fan. That means she's a Biden
fan. Let's go. She's riding with Biden. That's the only guy.
That was the only guy left. That was the last guy.
My single issue is did not touch that wall. Knowers knowers no
>> something gay. Daniel Adams for two. >> Uh, why
don't you have a girlfriend? Veto. Gelatinous Rube for 10. Veto.
You think asking the same question over and over again is going
to fix the problem. You need a social media manager, project
manager, something. Stop looping. Antagonist vision for five.
Ask Tony from Hack the Movies how he's so high energy lately.
Veto. I can help you with that if you want. Just hit me up on
Discord. All right. Um,
what else is there? You got anything >> Yeah, internet's
fixed. Revol.
>> I miss you. Wait, I don't I don't have any problem with
that. Like, I can watch somebody who does that, okay?
It's not because she's a woman. It's because she pretends she's
not. It's because she pretends she's not a noticer. Okay, that's
what it is. >> And I'm always going to miss you. And you
always You were a very important part of my life. >> Oh
boy. >> And uh Oh, boy. >> I have a deep fear that
that time is
so my under what I would expect to happen here is Dick goes is
always going to say, "Yeah, you right." I think
>> if that's how it has to be, it's tremendously sad.
>> It's like losing a friend. It's like losing a brother.
>> It's losing someone I cared about.
>> Just don't do this Eeyore thing. Oh, I'm sad about our
relationship, though. I'm very sad about it. I feel like I lost
a brother.
And come on, >> how do I put this? Uh, I deeply respect
you as a comedic talent,
as a as a as a man, as a person, as a and I I see the life you
have. I see the family you make. I see the smiles you bring to
This is getting gay. I'm being gay. Uh, started gay. It started
gay and only got gayer. Where's
I If I wasn't on Twitch, I would need Cherry to come in here
stat to say something about this. Okay, >> I'm on Twitch
though. Do not do that. Do not do that.
>> Dude, I could have hit
Oh, why was I not ready? I could have been doing it the whole
time. Oh, hold on. Do I have this on my soundboard still? I don't.
Oh, never mind. I don't even have it on my soundboard anymore.
>> Just have like the Nuto music. I see the life you have.
I see the family you make. I see the smiles you bring to This
is getting gay. I'm being gay. I think you have value. Don't
do the Titanic
>> How do you stop with the appropriate appropriate appropriate?
>> It's deeply sad to me
>> to think that I've lost
>> and I never I never felt like I was someone you would
want to have as a friend. And I understood that. I think we have
different ways of being.
>> You're a you're a boozer and a
>> womanizer. I don't [__] know. I'm a a gay.
What the [__] does that have to do with anything?
I'm just saying like there's a split. I'm a nerdy fat loser.
You're like Dr. Cool Guy. This is
>> the Titanic song threw me. You [__] it up.
All right. I don't know how to talk over the song.
>> he should have He should have leaned in. Veto should
have leaned in and started doing like uh some fake crying. He
Veto should have just leaned into it. That would have been funny.
>> Veto, you got to go to therapy about your dad, bro.
>> Shut the up. It's not about my
>> No way. No way. He said it, dude. I'm not your dad.
Veto. Veto. Veto. I have kids. You are not one of them. Veto.
I am not your dad. You don't do a podcast with your dad. Veto.
>> My dad. Shut up. >> Stop arguing with people online.
Argue with people who don't pay us money. If somebody's being
a to me, I might be a back. Why is that so bad?
All right. But look, I got it. If it's really aggravating you,
when a when a guy says, "Hey, Veto, you're a fat piece of go
you." Like, is that okay?
>> Okay. So, I obviously don't get it 100%. I don't know
what I'm allowed to do. I'm figuring it out. >> You can't
say I'm going to your girlfriend. You can't say there's refunds.
There's refunds now. >> You say you threaten one time and
you're suddenly like the threatener. What the guys? What is this?
Like >> immediately walked it back. Okay, let's be clear.
When you do 200 episodes of a podcast, you might occasionally
make a joke. Listen to me. Remember what I call the black guy
at the end two episodes ago? How do you [__] How
did he How is he so dead bed? >> That's funny.
>> Hold. I need to I need to be zoomed in. Listen to me.
Remember what I called the black guy at the end two episodes
ago? Sometimes you up >> sometimes. That's just no no reaction.
Just that's funny. Yeah, that that that
>> Nah, that was funny. >> Okay. Well, sometimes
it's funny and sometimes it's not. can say whatever you want
to black people. You can't say you're going to rape a woman.
Get the out of here. >> Sometimes you go a little You try
to make a joke and you up. I It's going to >> You don't
think you have like You don't think you like try to throw your
weight around and on people that you lose arguments with? Like
you don't think that you're like just crashing out over a superkiller
and telling people to go? >> I really don't think I'm I
really don't think I'm crashing out over superkiller. I think
all this like talk of vetos crashing out is like nuts. I don't
get it. What am I crashing out about when people go, "Hey, this
page and superkiller sucks." And I go, "You just don't get it."
>> That's a big speech. Like a speech that's crashing out.
>> But you interrupted with the thing cuz look look I genuinely
look this is why this is nuts.
By the way, I had no idea this segment was going to go this long.
I didn't realize they just spent the last half of their show
arguing. I just clicked it and I was like, "Oh, they'll do a
like quick 5minute thing. They'll fight back and forth and then
we're Dude, it's been like an hour and a half of this. It's been
at least an hour of >> This is nuts, >> bro. You
can't be calling people's wives for any reason. >> Just
say yes. Just say yes. Just say yes. Just say yes. I understand.
Just say yes. I understand. Just please, for the love of God,
veto, say yes. I understand. I understand. That was wrong. Please.
Please. Please. Please.
>> Yes.
Oh, okay. Hurdle. One of 100 cleared. All right. One of 100.
He will not say but. No. No. Spriggs. No. He will not say but.
He will not.
>> He will not. I don't believe it. >> You can't
be canceling live shows. You can't be canceling live shows. Like
>> I'm not cancing live shows.
>> Hurdle two. >> It's not happening. But a message
received
regardless. I don't know why we keep going back to again two
seconds. I called Patrick Melton and I said, "I'm being stupid."
You're right. Sometimes I'm going to be stupid. Hey, here's what
I'm going to >> No, no, no, no, no, no. You can't. Sometimes
I'm No. I think you got to Okay, bro. I hate to tell you this.
We do the show. Part of the show is Veto doesn't have a curtain
on his bathroom. Veto a cat with a Q-tip. I'm not 100%
there. What are >> you talking about? >> I'm a little
something up here is not 100% the way the rest of the world lives
their life. >> Yeah. So, so
can you understand that when I do things, it's not out of malice
and spite and trying to hurt you. I think that's where the disconnect
is. >> No, you're like you're Okay, listen. You can't have
a broken brain and say that you like you understand what I'm
thinking. You don't even understand what you are thinking. >> Don't
tell me it's not out to hurt me. It's just a pain in the ass.
>> When I go, "Oh my god, I haven't been able to reach
for a week." >> Oh, I'll call the person who lives with
him. No dude, never never never do that. Never do that. >> Well,
you let me make my point. The point is that I'm not doing it.
And you you you seem to think it's like Veto's trying to hurt
me. Veto's >> No. No. He's No,
Veto is trying to contact me. Veto. Veto, you are hurting him
by his boundary is Veto, don't contact me. I'm at you. I don't
like you right now. Don't contact me. I That's why I blocked
you on everything, right? That's where the line is. You are hurting
him by violating that boundary. This is what I mean. You have
a broken brain. You can't tell me a healthy brain what I'm
>> This is your problem. This is your problem. It's always
just like this is what's happening. But it's not. That's not
what happened. That's not what's >> I assumed you would
be home. I couldn't reach you. >> Yeah. So then then that's
too bad. Then don't reach me. >> Well, we were about to
do a real big live show and I was trying to figure out what was
going on with the show. >> What was going on is you losing
an argument with Riley and you trying to throw your weight around.
>> What argument? I Okay, I lost. I don't know what argument
I lost, but I'll >> blown Getting blown out. That was the
argument you lost. Getting [__] blown >> Blown
I'm blown out. I'm eternally
>> Yeah, you are.
>> You got blown out. Okay, on that note, Veto got blown
out. I'm ending the Twitch stream, guys. Head over to
Ending the Twitch stream. We're just going to go live on kick
only for the rest of the stream. Okay, I thought this was I was
going to cut off after this and and end the Twitch stream. I
thought it was going to be like an hour in, hour and a half in,
hour 20 in, maybe tops. Okay, hour 20 and instead this has got
an hour 45 now. So guys, ending the Twitch stream. I love you.
We're over on kick. Join up over there. We'll see you in a little
bit. Okay, have a good night, guys.
Go TW kick only. Kick only time.
Making the big bucks. Let's go. Turn off multireaming. Boom.
We're back. I'll give those guys like 90 seconds to switch over
so we don't miss anything. Just keep saying Vito gets blown out
in all the arguments with the fans. We'll see. We'll see. Maybe.
You got any examples of me getting blown out? >> I I understand
that you believe I got blowned out. >> I understand that.
>> Blown out. >> I think you think I'm a bad guy
>> and that's what I'm worried about. >> I just think
you given a compulsions. I mean, I have no willpower. >> Oh,
what >> is that wrong?
You human barric. >> I think we all I think we all have
compulsions.
Okay. You >> No, it's a weak problem. You like to drink.
You like to drink. I like to eat.
Veto's lagging out. >> Oh, he froze. He froze.
>> Stumped. Yeah, you need a dude. You need
>> Well, you need one. >> I mean, I don't give a
[__] You need >> All right, >> Veto.
Now Veto's winning. Now Veto's winning. Never get a Veto. Never
get a Never change. You're perfect the way you are. This is an
awesome situation. >> I don't need one. I know what's wrong
with me. And uh >> what is
>> a lot of things? Uh what's the top >> A deep dissatisfaction
with uh the state of the world.
>> What's the state of the world? >> Why aren't they
doing this in person? Uh that's literally this the the genesis
of the fight is
essentially like made up some about why why he doesn't want Veto
in the studio. Dick has like invented an inner ear problem where
like loud noises cause him pain. So he's like veto you can't
come into the studio. And then when he his other show, the D
show, his personal podcast, the co-host comes into his studio.
So it's just like veto, you're too loud and annoying to be near
me is like actually what he said. But I have a medical condition
that gives me like an out to not make this just my personal
>> World, what do you mean? >> Just a It's just a
mess, man. I'm not going to get into it. >> It's great.
We're getting rid of all the Mexicans. It's beautiful. >> I
really don't think getting rid of all the Mexicans is the solution
to our >> A lot of problems getting rid of the
Look, uh,
>> I feel like when we talk to each other,
>> it's not that bad. And I feel like the most I feel like
the most dangerous
>> Yeah. is when here's the thing. You hate me online.
I get it. Everybody does. Veto on >> isn't Mexican is very
Mexican. Yes. >> Twitter, VO on Reddit, Veto on Discord.
All you see is typing words. snarky at I'm very bad at typing
in a way that doesn't make me come across like a complete jackass.
>> But you're doing it aggressively. What do you mean come
across? Like you antagonize people directly all the time. >> I'm
just very cold the way I type. I mean like yeah, it's like maybe
standoffish sometimes and but like >> No, no, no. It's
not standoff. It's like antagonizing
and sarcastic. But it's usually antagonizing someone who's antagonizing
me. All day long I get people going, "Hey, you
like that's their right." >> Okay, then I can go you should
probably have a filter. >> Like I do that all the time.
Half the time you like it. You used to like it when I was doing
it to the right. >> Uh I can't think of something to correct
you on right now, Cherry, but I will >> To people when
I told other people to go
the right people, it's great to people who are not paying us.
It's absolutely wonderful. Okay. If a guy pays me money, he doesn't
get that's not a a ticket to come on my Twitter and go, "Hey,
fat. So, you whatever." I might go, "Yeah, I
>> No, you sit in Discords arguing with them all day. You
sit >> he has whatever Kelly Jean has apparently. Yes.
It's very similar. It's
>> Everyone is very similar
to fight with. >> They're all blocked. >> Okay. I'm
not fighting with everybody in
>> You didn't tell me to block them for a year. I don't
know. >> I did.
>> Okay. I didn't realize that me arguing with people in
the Discord was going to get to the point where it's like I >> Well,
that's why you canceled Hackamania because of your online arguments.
>> That's not why I canled hack. >> Yes, it is. And
because it led to Riley goofing on you and then you said, "I'm
done. I'm not doing I'm not doing >> I know that's how
you
>> Yeah. So you better learn, you better in incorporate
that into history cuz that's what it's going to be. >> I
have incorporated what you believe
>> And I understand that is your interpretation of things.
I accept that's your interpretation of things >> and that's
the reality. >> It is your reality. >> That's what
happened. That's what >> We're not we're not going to bring
this. That's how it happened to everybody as far as you can tell.
>> Yeah. See, I mean this >> we don't we shouldn't
fight with people who aren't going to give us content. Okay.
Only only the content. That's that's the focus. Okay. We focus
on the stream. This is what I mean. It's just like this constant.
>> It's not constant. I just don't think I think I have
a different series of events in my head and I don't want to relitigate.
The guy with the broken brain has the correct series of events
in his head. Okay. >> I think I was more intimately connected
to what was going on and all the different things that have happened.
>> Yeah. Stuff was going on. You arguing with Riley. >> Well,
I'm not arguing with Riley. >> And then it was Skitso Sean.
Oh, somebody else. I'm not arguing with and I was not arguing
with Skittles Sean. That never happened. There was no argument
there at all. So that's a completely new thing. Hi Scraps. How
you doing? There was no argument. >> Why don't you show
up with some energy? Show up with energy. That's it. You know,
for the fans, >> how Okay, >> show up with some energy.
>> Hold on. How about Stop. Get the look off your face.
What is this [__] >> Well, I mean, it's some
kind of scam that you're about to I can hear the sales pitch
coming. Yeah, it is a sales pitch. Can I do a sales pitch?
>> Uh, sure. Go for it. >> All right. Hi. Hi. My
name is Veto Jazwaldi. I've got a very exciting product to sell
you, sir. Can I have a minute of your time? >> No. You
never never say, "Can I have a minute?" No, that's that's hawk
that's hacky salesmanship. Okay. That is that's your hawking
garbage. Okay. Don't ask. Can you have a minute of their time?
Come on, man. >> You talking to me?
>> Oh, yeah. Sure. >> Fantastic. Can I come into
your home? You got a lovely home here. >> [__]
now. Get out of here.
>> Dick should have said no. I have kids. >> I'll
just stay here at the door.
>> Here's the product, guys. Thank you for not yourself.
>> Stop reading. Let me finish.
>> Dude, imagine having so many super chats that you can
just read them over your co-host whenever he's annoying. As soon
as as soon as you're annoyed with your co-host, you just start
reading your mountain of super chats.
And all the super chats are that co-host. This guy for $5 says,
"Veto, thanks for not killing yourself."
Let me finish the Mr. Tattoo Charlie for two. You complete me.
MK minimal for five. I don't know what you guys are on about.
I'm having a blast. Yeah. A Caro for uh 14 for 10. And just like
that, the show is hilarious again. Thanks for the Titanic bit.
Citizen Johnny Rico for two. Omega. Omega.
I heard that too. Uh Bender for five. Was totally gay for Veto.
Even picked up his parcels. Just stop crashing out, Veto. Jesus
bands for five. Uh, Butterball, he was never your friend. You
were content. You also need to separate business and personal
life. Justin Rolland for two. To the Please be patient. I have
autism. Have fun. Jacob uh W Gamer for therapy, man. I'm too
smart for it is the real problem.
>> Dude, I already know what they're going to say. >> I
can tell what was going to for therapy to work. MK minimal for
two. Don't get blown out. Get blown in. Boo time. Veto. Uh, Autumn
for two. I pray I pay for drama, not therapy. This is boring.
Shoe Box Kingdom for five. Veto, you're great. We love you, but
this whole episode is pure secondhand embarrassment for you.
Please stop crashing out so >> I don't care. This is not
crashing out. Will you guys stop saying crashing out? >> Crashing
out. >> Just cuz you learned the term crashing out. Every
two seconds I get, he's crashing out. He's crashing out. It's
>> How many How many times did you say that you were the
talent in the last year? How many times have you intimated? >> Not
nearly enough. Hold on. What? Do you think I'm When I say that,
do you think I'm saying you're not the talent?
>> Veto. Veto, you're crashing out. Veto, you're crashing
out. Veto. Veto, you're crashing out. Veto, you got to stop crashing
out, buddy. >> What do you What do you think? What do you
think I mean? How many times have you said the talent? How many
times have you said it? >> I have no idea. What do you
think that
>> What do you think that means? >> How many times
have you said hoot? What under what circumstances have you said?
>> I think three times I believe maybe. >> Oh, you're
way I think you've said it. I think you've said it way way more
times than that. >> I don't think I I'm sure somebody can
make a super cut. >> How just you know how many times have
you said that? I could probably go in Discord and search your
name. >> Said three. >> I just said three. I gave
you an >> Well, I'll tell you what I think. I think uh
I think you say that as a joke and eventually uh it becomes >> they
uh they bounced way up in their viewership when they had their
last big crash out like this was their like falloff and they
bounced way up
and that that's pretty good growth. They're still they're just
coming down to where they were before now like where they were
basically when they had their their like falling out before.
They're barely they're not even there yet. They're still above
that. So, this could all be new content. They're making money.
They're just doing the thing that's going to make them a bunch
of money. That seems very possible. >> And you start to
believe. >> It doesn't actually seem possible to me. This
seems like quite real. But I I feel like it's one of those things
where it's like, you know, it's like Darius. It's like 50/50.
It's a bit and it's not a bit. These are real concerns. These
are real problems has, but they're also going to play it up for
the the camera. >> That [__] is a joke. And
eventually, uh, it becomes cope and you start to believe it.
You start acting. Oh, I'm not saying it as a joke. >> I
think you're saying that as a joke, but I think if I think one
of >> No. What? Wait, what? What do you think it is? It
it means when I say I'm the talent. What do you What like Why
is that negative to you?
>> I uh >> You're all Do you realize you're also
the talent, right? We're the talent. >> No, we are nothing.
I am not the talent. Nor would I ever. >> That's just That's
just a show business term for the comedian, the performer. That's
the talent. >> You're not in show business, dude. >> This
is not show business. >> Literally, this is literally show
>> This is not show business, bro. This is This is losers
with a microphone. >> It's entertainment. This is not show
>> Comedy. Okay. >> This is not entertainment. Veto.
>> I think it is. >> This is losers with a microphone
for cash. The bottom of the barrel begging for money. Busking.
That's what this is. We are in the top 50 [__] super
chatted shows on YouTube. We have a top 200
>> That is exactly what it is. And guys, if you like the
content, you Yes, you chatter can make this stream go even longer.
Okay, you can you can go ahead. You can follow me on every platform.
Speaking of busking, okay? Hey, hello guys. I'm here to sell
you my my cheap fake watches. Okay, you can you can follow on
every platform. Join the Discord. discord.gg/jstlk.
Get in the community, join the VCs, have some fun. Okay, if you
want to make the stream go longer, you can donate in a couple
different ways. You can go to Kickbot, you can buy a TTS message,
you can go to Kickbot, you go to Streamlabs,
$2 minimum across both, I believe. Okay, you can buy a TTS message.
Shows up on screen, gets read out. I'll definitely engage with
it. Okay, guaranteed. If you actually buy TTS, you can sub on
kick. You can sub on Twitch. You can give me your Twitch primers.
You can give subs on kick. Subs on kick are the best way to donate
for more time on the stream. It's a 955 split for me. I appreciate
every donation to the stream. We're currently doing $30 per hour.
We put the two hours up there. Okay. Looking to hit that goal.
I appreciate everything. And yes, I am a I am a hobo on the streets.
Okay. Spare change. Spare change. Sir, any donations? Any dodos?
Any donos? I don't know why I suddenly gained a British accent,
but that's what I think of hobos as. Okay, I've got my cup. I'm
holding it out. Any any change? Any change? I need to buy some
booze. Any any dodos? Any dodos?
>> Thank you guys for Thank you guys for all the support.
I really appreciate it. There's also the Patreon. patreon.com/jdk.
You guys all joined up last night for a little bit of extra content.
Appreciated everybody being there. I think we watched some lurbox
stuff. Join the Patreon, guys, if you want uh additional content.
Thank you very much. >> This is a as much Here's here's
here's a I'm not going to get too into it, but
>> you're Dulu, bro.
>> Dulu. There's very few guys who are as blessed as we
are. I don't know why you think of this as small potatoes. To
me, this this is huge.
>> Well, I said what I I said what I had to >> Okay.
Do my pitch. Yeah. Hold on. I was doing I was doing a whole bit.
Here's my >> Do yourselves pitch. Let's go. >> It's
called The Biggest Problem in the Universe. And uh
it's had its ups. It's had its downs.
But here's my here's my pitch to you. I want to recommmit to
this show for a period of time. We can figure out what that period
of time is. We do the best show we can do. Dude, here here's
the thing. Here's the implication from this. The implication
is you're not here showing up and trying to do the best you can
do, right? That's what the implication is there. That's going
to make furious. Why the [__] would you say this?
I'm going to recommit. I'm going to be here. I'm going to be
present. Yeah. Why did you show up and not do those things? like
it's just going to everything. And if was in a decent place with
Veto, they maybe he could see that in a good way, right? But
he's not. He hates him right now. Of course, there's major downsides
to exactly what Veto is saying right now. Be easy to point out.
Whenever I hear these arguments between Dick and Veto, I wonder
how on earth uh how on earth can the show possibly continue,
but then it does. I think Veto can put it behind him. I just
don't know. I don't know if D's going to do it this time. We
go balls to the wall.
high energy
bits, maybe a guest here or there. Whatever. Whatever. >> I'm
not doing guests now. [__]
Okay, I got you. Don't get hung up on the guests. We don't got
to do it now cuz let's be clear, you're a new dad. We put it
off whatever. I think we got something good. I think we had something
great.
I think it went off the rails.
I want to do what I can to get it back on the rails. I'm not
going to therapy. That's not part of it. But
I will not fight.
That being said, if you see me do something and you go, "Hey,
Veto, that constitutes fighting." Don't like I'll try my best.
I don't 100. I'm trying my >> Who are you talking to?
>> You I'm not I'm not saying you're doing some [__]
online. I don't give a [__] >> I want to do
I think we have >> What are you talking about?
All Veto has to do is say, "I'm going to show up at the studio.
We're going back to the studio. I'm going to show up at the studio
and we're going to make this work and I'm not going to take any
more of your time. I'm just going to show up for the show. I'm
going to be ready to go and we'll make it work and I'm going
to make my money. Okay, let's go." Okay, look.
Is this is this the closing of a book or the start of a new chapter?
>> Bro, you [__] need therapy. Like, I can
you stop
therapy. You are so
>> I'm just going to like I can already see exactly I can
already see exactly how sees it. You're you're the co-host. You
own half the show. It would be a huge headache to try to kick
you off. So show the up. Do your job and we're good. Literally
just show up and do your job. Literally just show up and do your
job and we're all good. That's it. You don't have to you don't
have to sell me. You don't have to recommmit. Just I show up
every day. I I every day I'm here. I try to do my job the best
I can. That's all I want from you. And as long as you do that,
we're cool. But if I think you're like, if I think you're with
the show, I'll be >> therapy. Like you are
therapy. >> You are so needy. You are so needy.
I mean, it's like you need it's like you need some kind of a
win. Something you say, I got I got that. I got it. I can take
it. I can take it home with me. Bro, I don't need a win. I just
want to
have some very simple conversation about the show. >> No,
I'm not having a conversation with you about it's a waste of
time. >> It's not a waste of time. We have a big show.
We should be like coordinating. >> I don't know why you're
trying to talk me out of it. Like go Why don't you go outside
and talk a rock into moving? There's Dude, look at look at me.
Look at my head. There is zero chance you're going to affect
what's in my head at
>> I don't give a about anything you're saying. You have
no idea what's in my head. You don't even know what's in your
>> I really don't. >> You have You know nothing,
Jon Snow. What are you talking about? >> You know where
I've been, Lou. >> So then So then So say to me,
whatever we're doing, we're just on a flat road and we'll see
what happens. Cuz that's what it's that's >> whatever we're
doing on a flat road and we'll see what happens.
>> That Yeah, but you didn't need to. Here's the thing.
You didn't need to hear that, right? It's inherently requiring
something of just all you need to do is not need stuff from don't
be needy with him, right? That's all he's asking for. Don't be
needy. Don't be needy right now and we're good. And Veto's like,
I need you to tell me that like things will be okay if I show
up again. And like, yeah, that's the whole point is like you
constantly need me to re like revalidate what you what you're
doing. It's not good. I will treat it like a flat road.
I'll come in. I'll hit my mark. I'll bring some energy. >> No,
you have to bring energy, though. It's You have to bring energy.
Like,
>> I'm gonna really try my best. >> Nah, you got
to really >> Well, I mean, I'm telling you, part of
what gets me energized. You want to know what gets me energized?
>> I don't give a [__] calories. I mean, coming
up with ideas. What do you mean? >> I'm buying buying stuff.
Buying when I'm hanging out with my buddy, my friend. Dick. When
I'm hanging out with my friends, I feel energized. I feel good
to go. Right. That's what That's what Vito is going to say. I
I feel energized when is my buddy. When I'm here with my friend
stuff and then and then making money on it at some point in the
future. >> When I have energy, when I'm when I'm putting
on the best show ever. >> Don't say it. Don't say it. Don't
say it cuz that's going to be another thing you need from It's
going to be another thing you need. Don't say it. >> I'm
excited about the show. >> Oh, excited about the show.
Okay. Okay. >> Be excited. Anyway, it's a job. No one gives
a [__] about your mental state. Show up and act like
it. Get your [__] life together. Get your act
>> You're here to make money, not to be not to have your
ego stroked. Grow up. >> It's not about having my ego stroked.
I just don't know why we can't have fun and have an exciting
show. >> I'm having a great time. I don't know why you're
not having fun. >> I just cuz I don't know what's going
on, >> I feel like I feel like spent this whole time telling
you exactly what's going on, dude. All right. Come on, man. >> Well,
uh,
>> you need to go to therapy, bro. >> I'm not going
to therapy. Stop saying >> You need to go to therapy. >> Why
do I got to go to therapy? >> Cuz your brain's all up.
>> What is up about my brain? >> I don't know. You
don't know what's coming or going. You got way too much invested
in like a comedy show in a podcast. It's all the things you're
saying are all up.
>> So, okay. Okay. So, I mean, I guess that's where the
disconnect is. Is that I look at this thing and I go, "This is
a big exciting thing,
>> And you don't, right? >> No. Now you're just making
this is like why you need therapy because you to understand things,
you have to like pervert it and invert it and say weird [__]
back that I didn't say. >> Just tell All right. >> I
didn't say I don't care about. I said you have all this weird
[__] wrapped into a comedy show that you shouldn't
be there. Like like validation of yourself is [__]
up. What a bad time to freeze for Veto. What a horrible time
to
>> Oh, he didn't freeze. >> Veto, just say uh Mike
for two. Veto, just say I'm sorry you feel that way. The monkey
bros for two. You mad, Veto, you mad? You mad? You mad. Veto.
>> Spider return for two. The guy crashing out says he's
not crashing out. Gelatus r for two. Veto is castanza, but Seinfeld
was a hor show. Rox is for two. Veto. Top 50. Buskers. A for
two. This is talent. JVC for two. Veto has narcissistic personality
disorder. Manny must seeking validation in your career is fine.
Seeking validation in your career is fine, but if your validation
is just from people telling you you did a good job, then that's
going to come and go, right? He said rhoxis was apparently one
of the guy's names. I don't know if it's rhinox, but um
yeah, seeking validation your career is fine, but it should be
in the arc of your career, not like the moment of your career,
right? The arc of your career is how you should feel validated,
not the moment. If you feel validated only from the moments,
then you're going to go up and down. You're going to ping-pong
around, right? Because you'll have down points to your career.
But what you should do when you have a down point in your career
is you say, "Where was I a year ago? Where was I 5 years ago?"
Right? That's what you need to do. Oh, I'm way bigger than I
was then. Oh, we're still going in the right direction. This
is just a this is just a speed bump. It's not like a pit. Okay,
cool.
Do people not tell him he does a good job already? Uh, lots of
people do. Well, yeah. I think he just has a lot of people who
he's not great with it. Five had a 20 plus comedy career. Veto's
had a couple funny YouTube videos whose better perspective on
the show is spider for five. Veto. Stop arguing the internet.
Stop arguing the internet. Stop arguing the internet. Stop arguing
the internet. Stop arguing the internet. Uh gig of war too. You
regret giving him an IP. >> Dude, I can't believe they
just This is um
I've I've had this a couple times. Okay. Like you just stop covering
whatever you're covering. You're just going to argue with the
other person. It's like uh it's it's good content sometimes,
but sure doesn't seem like it can last for very long. Of any
of Veto's other endeavors done outside of uh things Duke is involved
in, he might just actually suck and is the last lifeline for
his belief in his career. No, no, no. He's done some other stuff.
Like some of his solo comedy stuff's been wellreceived. Like
his Twitter is followed. He's not He's not like He is a funny
guy. He went on Kicker Keep. Didn't he win Kicker Keep a couple
times? I think he went like top two, top three on Kicker Keep.
He is a funny guy in a vacuum,
right? He is.
He just Yeah, he just um I don't know. I think kind of is his
dad. I don't know. He like doesn't want to with sometimes. He
should He should actually go back and forth with him. I think
No, because the IP doesn't mean anything. Podcasts are just between
people. The name's totally irrelevant. That's a It's a It's That
was the joke from the beginning. The name doesn't mean anything.
I I don't think people get that the show doesn't exist. >> Do
you? >> The show is I mean I I guess you could do a version
of the show without me. I guess I could do a version of the show
without you, but it wouldn't be the same >> Yours would
suck though.
>> I don't think so. >> I mean, didn't you try it
with that Tuesday Night Griff thing? >> No, that was a
totally different thing and I didn't I never thought it didn't
>> cuz I didn't find a good stable of guys. I got to find
the right guys. >> What about corn boys? You tried that?
It didn't work. Now, Corn Boys is going to be good.
>> I'm the one I'm the one who does this over and over
and over, though. I make successful podcasts over and over and
>> That's That's just facts. I think could start another
podcast and it would be at like $5,000 a month in revenue within
6 months,
right? Might even be faster than that, but like that's just like
a once a week podcast, probably $5,000 a month in revenue if
he did it with basically anybody. like he could do it with with
somebody nobody's ever heard of, right? And it'd be I think at
minimum five grand, maybe even higher. And that's that's I would
call that successful right off the bat, right? >> Yeah.
Me Maddox, me and Sean, me and you, me and Johnny, I got you
track record. That's what I'm saying. >> That's what Manny
Musketss is saying. >> Uh yeah. Okay. Maybe you're the
maybe you're the Howard Stern, you know, no >> Howard Stern.
I'm just saying his number
hit hit.
>> I've had successful podcasts. >> You can't even
>> say that. You can't even say that I make hits. You can't
even say that I make hits. What the [__] is wrong
with you? You need a psychiatrist.
You can't even say that I make hits podcast. I obviously do.
>> If I had the archives of Violence Island, you'd say,
"Well, that's a pretty good podcast right there." Violence Island.
Somebody has those episodes. Oh, Matt C88 says, "I'm blocked
from super chats." [__] Amazing. Amazing.
>> How can you be blocked from super chats if you >> blocked
everybody when you threw a fit two two year a year ago? >> Well,
then how did he send a super chat? >> He said that in the
chat. I just read it in the chat.
>> He can't He's not chatting. He can't be blocked from
super chats and be able to chat. That's not a thing. You're either
blocked or you're not. >> Sorry, Matt. You heard it here.
You're not blocked. >> Something's wrong with your credit
card.
Yeah. Okay. >> That on my medallion lore. Is that a replica?
I don't know. I do know. >> Eternal for two. Veto, you
absolutely need therapy for real, bro.
>> Wasn't that the Wasn't that the meme last time? Put
it on and people were joking that it it cursed Veto. Actually,
it just like skipped dick and went straight to Veto. >> I
will never
go to therapy. And that's the bottom line. There's no there's
no >> Never seek therapy. Never get to talk to a lady who
goes, "Yeah, you [__] around and then you die. What
am I going to get? You're always begging your your friends to
call you and work things out. I mean, you're clearly like seeking
conversation and human contact.
>> No. No. What do you mean? >> Okay. You're not
insinuating yourself uh with conversations ever.
>> I'm not trying to have conversations. >> You're
not calling them over and over saying, "Let's talk about this.
Let's go to dinner and talk this out." You're not ever saying
that kind of stuff.
>> I've sent you I sent you a email and I said, "Hey, I
don't >> say no. You don't need to explain it. Just say
no." I mean, what what's explaining it going to do? >> I
don't understand why we can't go to
>> Me and you
>> because I don't have a week night. I don't want to,
number one, and I also don't have the time to waste going to
dinner with you or spend going to dinner with you. >> So,
you would not enjoy going to dinner? >> Uh, I would probably
enjoy it, but I don't want to do it. Uh,
>> okay. Well, that's that's good to know. At least I know
that you would have a good time. >> How did you uh I like
see what I mean? I
>> Well, I mean, here's here's my my fear is that you're
like any interaction with me is just like, you know, you want
to get out of it as quickly as you can that you don't want to
you don't you can't tolerate me that I'm intolerable. >> Well,
uh I mean at some point, yeah, because it's like just internet
[__] >> I don't want to be around that crap.
>> Okay.
You know, >> so if Veto becomes a more tolerable
>> No, I didn't say that. >> But that's what it feels
like.
>> I It feels like being around me, being near me, having
to talk to me is the >> Bro, you need like you need real
friend. >> I had something else up. I thought that was
playing them off of the show. Whoops. Whoops. That's my bad.
It feels like being around me, being near me, having to talk
to me is uh >> Bro, you need like you need real friends.
Like you need you need real people that aren't this internet.
>> Dirk the corn boy. >> Yeah, but you turn you tried
to turn that into internet. Do you see how up that is?
>> We want to make content. It's fun. Guys like to make
stuff with their buddies. >> Okay. Okay. I got to I got
a million things I got to do. I got to make friends. I got it.
In the meantime, you're right. I do worry about annoying people
and I don't want to annoy you. So, you are super
>> I got it. I got to figure out how to be less annoying.
>> And I've I've heard some I've heard what will make me
less annoying to you and I will work on the the Yeah, I don't
know how many times I have to say it. The thing that would make
him less annoying to dick is literally just not having to be
like literally not saying the phrase I need to be less annoying,
right? Like that's just don't need something. Don't need things.
Find the things from other places. Find your validation from
other places. You don't need it from Dick. He's not your dad.
He's not your dad. He's not your dad. He's not your dad. He's
not your dad. He's not your dad. Dick is not your father. He's
not going to make you okay.
If you think of any If you think of it, cuz I cuz I >> He
doesn't even have to delete Twitter. That's the funny thing.
He can get in fights with whoever he wants. All he has to do
is not make that even probably even customers, okay? To some
extent. All he has to do is not make it fault. Not ban them.
If he if he if he doesn't like the way the fight went, don't
ban those people. And just don't make it a problem. Don't tell
Dick that something needs to change. That's all you got to do.
Just don't need things from Dick. Dick's a busy guy.
value. Shut the [__] up. I know you and I look, I
don't know how much of it is
>> None of this is performative.
I have a [__] family. I don't give a [__]
about this online stuff. >> I know. I know. Okay. I'm not
talking about online stuff. I'm talking about >> That's
what this is, >> bro. I
I'll just say let's let's go take a peek on at on how uh how
much Dick doesn't care about online stuff. Maybe he's not been
tweeting at all. Maybe he's not been tweeting at all because
actually, you know, he's he's like with his kids or whatever.
Obviously, you can't be with your kids all the time. It's totally
fine if he tweets, but just the idea that he's like, I don't
care about this online stuff from is a little bit I'm like
51 minutes ago, 3 hours ago, 3 hours ago, 3 hours ago, 3 hours
ago, 4 hours ago, 4 hours ago, 5 hours ago, 6 hours ago, 7 hours
ago, 9 hours ago, 10 hours ago, 11 hours ago, 19 hours ago. Right?
He does tweet a lot for somebody who says they don't care about
online. Now, that doesn't mean he's obviously that that probably
took 30 minutes out of his day to do all those tweets, right?
So, I'm not saying he's not taking care of his kids or anything.
I'm just saying I don't like when people say, "I don't care about
online." And then they're super online. He's plugged in. Okay.
Is plugged in. He knows what's going on online all the time.
You care about online [__] >> I have spent
three years at your house once a week. I know your >> just
doesn't want to care about Vito knows online [__]
right? Know my family. Sorry. That is the difference between
he keeps up on cultural issues for his shows, right? But he doesn't
want to keep up on Veto's personal uh what do you call it? Veto's
personal neurosis. No thank you.
Politics? Yes. Comedy? Yes. Like any current issues? Sydney Sweeney?
Yes. Veto's personal neurosis? No thank you. Get the [__]
out of here. >> You've come over for parties. You don't
know my family. >> You're right. I don't know your family.
>> No, I am right. You don't know these people. Will you
come over for gettogethers?
What are you talking about, man? >> I'm not trying to say
I know them >> Well, then why are you saying it? Why are
you saying it? >> Cuz I'm just making a broad generic point.
I know you're going to hammer in on that. And when I say family,
I mean also your wife.
>> I don't know why you would say these things. It's insane.
>> What is insane about it? Your
>> What is What is Veto not supposed to call his mom? What
are you doing, bro? You're telling him he can't call his mom.
That's [__] up. Okay, that's [__] up.
>> Really? Why would you say these things? >> I know
where they sleep. >> You need real friends, dude.
No, no, no, no. Stop going down this line. Stop immediately.
Stop >> You just you you need therapy and you need real
friends and you got to stop wrapping your validation up in this
online [__] It's totally crazy. Not. Look, all I'm
saying is >> it's exhausting.
>> He's playing. >> I'm doing it for the fans, but
it's exhausting. Like, I'm sure they understand why it's totally
intolerable. >> I don't I don't even know what we're talking
about right now. Uh,
>> you've been a part of my life. Thank you very much.
And, uh, >> buy the shirt if you killed. >> Buy the
shirt. >> Make sure you buy the shirt. That's what it's
there for. All right. Goodbye, everybody. Go to patreon.com/
>> Um, you've been a part of my life.
Like, dude, h it's just up that I I understand that going to
do that. I don't know why Veto doesn't. Okay, >> we'll
see you next time. >> Just a little [__] up.
Wow, dude. That was so much longer than I thought it was going to
be. Holy [__] that was a long ass segment. Holy moly.
Okay, if you guys don't remember, there was a comment about Voldemort
that I do want to check out from the very beginning. Okay. And
it's like you're reading a book. >> So, apparently apparently
they started talking about reading books. I'm I'm going to check
this out. >> What do you think? >> A YouTube comment
about this. >> Uh, did you ever own a Kindle? I never had
a Kindle. >> Yeah, I bought one pretending I would read
or thinking I was a reader, but I probably read one book on it.
>> When's the last time you read a book? >> Oh, I
don't know. Maybe never. >> I'm not I'm not I'm not judging
cuz I say also never. Maybe about never that I last read a book.
I don't even remember it. What was the last book you read? >> That's
a great question.
I think I picked up uh
Tinker Taylor Soldier Spy. >> The move like the novelization
of the >> Well, I have an old paperback of it. It doesn't
have it doesn't say from the hit movie or whatever. >> I
read a I read a Mortal Kombat. >> That's a good problem.
That's a good problem, by the way. But when you when you get
the version of the book that's got all the movie [__]
on it and you're like a kind of this kind of cheapens it. >> Yeah.
Oh yeah. Like Harry Potter when >> now motion picture from
Warner Brothers. >> I hate when they do that. I don't even
>> I was always bothered that uh >> the first >> I
don't even read that. >> Harry Potter the philosopher stone
is like a real thing and then they brought it to America and
they're like American kids are call it the sorcerer's stone.
Uh, you know, it's like a real magical artifact. You mean? >> Well,
it's like it's like a historical thing that like alchemists search
for was the idea of the philosopher stone or
>> And then they brought it to America and they're like,
"Call it wizard
>> I'm trying to do this one book for like two years. Uh,
yeah. I get stuck on books, too. I usually just stop reading
those books entirely, man. I'm read I'm rereading Kings of the
Wild right now. It's like such a good book. If any of you guys
haven't seen or read Kings of the Wild, it is so good. Um,
yeah, it's basically like a It's not an allegory. It's like basically
it's like imagine fantasy
parties like fantasy um what do you call them? Like a like a
Final Fantasy party, something like that. Like a a World of Warcraft
party that has got like a tank and stuff, but it's all um it's
like all rock themed. So the the parties are called bands and
they go touring and it's like the person who like finds them
their quest is called their booker and it's all music themed.
They all kind of represent existing bands and stuff. It's just
but it's also written really well. The characters are like really
I don't know three-dimensional. It's um
it's just really really good. I can't I don't want to like talk
about it too much. I feel like I'll spoil it, but it is a great
book. It's an amazing book. You guys should all read it. If you
read fantasy at all, it's fantastic. Nicholas, Kings of the Wild.
Wild with a a Y. WD.
>> Sure.
With a >> That's better. That's better. >> The Sorcerer
Stone is better. >> Why would anyone want to see a philosopher
stone? No one gives a about
they have >> You know what? From a marketing perspective,
you tell a kid it's about a philosopher stone, the kid goes,
"What's >> I don't know why they just call it the wizard
stone, though. That sounds >> the wizards rock. They should
have called it Harry Pard and wizard rock. That would have been
way better. Way better book series. >> It is just
called me an fsler when I told her I read fantasy. Um, don't
let women talk to you like that. They won't respect you. Don't
don't let them call you anor, okay? They won't respect you. >> It
is funny that, you know, they tried to be a little bit sophisticated
and give the kids a little some like historical thing and it's
like, nah, it wizards. Who gives a [__] I didn't
know it was called the wizard stone here. >> Yeah, the
sorcerer stone. I think that's what the movie >> Sorcerer
Stone.
>> I don't I don't think I watch those movies, man. >> You
didn't watch any of the Harry Potter >> No, I hate Harry
Potter. >> I uh I finally tried to force myself to watch
them and
>> man, they are they're a real mixed bag. I don't know.
Oh, it's a global phenomenon that, you know, has inspired,
>> you know, generations of cat women to buy fanciful scarves
and fake wands and then throw them all out because, you know,
solidarity for trans people >> and then pull it all back,
you know, once they, you know, never mind, I'm not trans people
anyway.
>> there's still Harry Potter boycotts going on. I found
out there's a new Harry Potter board game. And if you go to the
board game forums, they're all reviewbombing it, saying, "Well,
this just gives money to a trans phobe." And you're like, "Yeah,
I don't know, man.
>> I think she's fine. I think she's >> she's not
even that transphobic, but also it's like it's a fantasy." >> I
don't care. She's made it very clear. She's like, "Guys, I have
more money than God at this point. I have a whole theme park.
Okay, you think I'm worried about you guys buying a board game
adaptation? I don't care. What do I got for you? >> Which
one of the uh child wizards did you think was the most attractive
>> in the in the whole series? >> In the Yeah. In
the in the book versus the movie. Which one?
>> Ching Chang. His Asian girlfriend. >> I knew you
were going to say Ching
>> Actually, it's Cho Chang. What the guys? >> you
got to love that. JK Rowling goes, "Uh, let's put an Asian girl
in there." And I don't know. Just call her Ching Chang. Nobody's
going to give a [__] about that. And it was weird
when Harry learned that spell in the fifth book uh street and
he would cast it at the Muslim wizard [__] all over
themselves in the street or the Indian wizards. Do you remember
that? >> The Patel effect Patel. Yeah, he didn't make it
to the tri- wizard tournament. >> Oh no. Uh >> Harry
Potter does suck on a number of levels. Like >> wait, is
that is that a thing that >> I don't recall that happening.
curious to me why it connected with a certain gener. >> Okay,
hold on. Just just real quick. I want to remind people why we're
watching this. Apparently says he hates Harry Potter and then
he is cover hates Harry Potter. He didn't read the books. He
didn't watch the movies. And then he like actually knows meticulously
like lore about the books, like all the memes about the books.
>> Generation. Have I told you my Harry Potter theory of
why it connected with that generation? >> What? What generation?
You're talking about children or women? Yeah. Like children of
the children of like the late 90s early 2000s.
>> Okay. Why? >> Cuz uh unlike you know other narratives
>> like uh you watch Star Wars >> the Holocaust.
What do you mean? >> Yeah. Classic. No classic like hero.
>> What are you saying? >> I'm talking like the hero's
journey stuff. That wasn't funny at all. The hero,
you know, even if it's a fanciful far off uh land or whatever,
Luke Skywalker is essentially human.
Even though he has friends who are aliens or whatever, at the
end of the >> he's working to and he finds out he's a
>> he's still helping his human friends who are not Jedi,
right? He still cares about Han Solo
>> and Lando Calarisian. Okay. >> What about Dances
with Wolves? Kevin Cosner is helping Indians,
>> but he but Indians are
human beings as well. >> Ah, okay.
Harry Potter is about finding outer's list, veto, >> stop
bringing up the Holocaust. There's only so much. Look, Harry
Potter is about a kid who finds out that he's basically not human.
He's a different race entirely.
>> Like, wizards are not >> human beings.
>> They're they're they're considered human beings, dude.
>> No, they're not human beings. The way they talk about
like the human world is as if they are not human, >> but
they're talking about people. They're not talking about fun guys.
They're talking about fat like his >> But the point is
in any other This is a narrative about a child who goes who gets
a letter that says, you know, all these idiots stupid humans.
>> Oh, this is like it's just wish fulfillment as in you're
you're going to get a letter. So, this is not even unique, right?
This is why isseekis fit with people. If you guys are anime fans,
you know anything about anime, there's a genre called isekai.
As in, you're a total loser. 30-year-old who has no career, no
education, nothing going on for you. You're like a total loser
and then you die and you get reborn of fantasy world and you
can be cool now. Yeah, that's like that's exactly what they're
he's going to say for Harry Potter, right? All these people who
like were losers growing up, they're like, "Oh, what if I was
like a wizard and I could have been cool?" that you're surrounded
by. Not only are you better than them, you're so much better
than them that you're not they're not even of your race. You
are of a different master race that has mastery of elements beyond
their comprehension.
>> You're Harry. You bet. >> Yeah. He's the master
race. That's what Harry Potter is. Because in a traditional narrative,
you would go to the fanciful world. You would obtain all this
knowledge and information and
>> And you would take that back to your human world to
make the human world a better place to save humanity, to elevate
humanity. This is instead finding out you're a member of a higher
cast, completely cutting yourself off from your separate life,
>> like and and then just going, "Yeah, we're wizards.
We only care about wizard stuff. Anything that's going on with
humanity doesn't matter because we are a different, higher cast
than them." I mean, I don't know. Is that >> I think that's
I think it poisoned a generation cuz that's a generation that
never learned like, hey, you're supposed to make the world around
you better. It's No, you are [__] again. You're still
on this save the world.
>> Well, you got to you got to get kids to at least think
that, you know, we're all part of a a human community. We're
all working for something. >> No, you got to teach kids
to cut the weak members of the tribe.
Cut them off. Put them down. Well, if you want your kid to be
a genocidal
uh then genocide. They're not people. They're weak. >> Well,
that's what Harry Potter would tell you. You'd say, "Well, they're
just muggles. Burn them alive." >> No, don't do that though.
Don't they save the uh elves? I can't believe. Okay, hold on.
Hold on. Yeah, this is like the beginning of the episode we just
watched. I can't believe says this at the beginning and then
Vita goes, "Look, I'm showing you my belly. Will you be nice
to me now? I'm showing you my belly. Will you be nice to me now?
Could you be nice to me? Please be nice to me." and stuff or
something. >> I don't know. There's an elf and a sock.
I know. They're always They're always trying to get an AI of
the elf to do weird to They're always trying to an AI of the
elf in my Discord. So, I know that there is one. >> World
War II happened in the Harry Potter universe, and they didn't
do >> They were busy having they were busy cartoon now.
>> Wait, I I thought the whole point of World War II was
that it was Grindlewald. Grindleald was I thought World War II
was like a cover for Grindleald like massacring people.
Isn't that the case? Am I crazy? I thought that's what it was.
>> No, no, no, no. I'm going to start the show. I can't
do this type of World War
>> Harry Potter is about abandoning humanity. That's the
bottom line.
problem
in the universe.
Oh, that's the that's that's where that's that's the first miss
right there. Okay. Or at least that's one of the first misses.
That is not high energy. Have you guys listened to Veto do this
another time
>> He goes biggest
in the universe,
right? He does like the whole thing in the universe. >> Welcome
to the biggest problem in the universe. The only show that ranks
every problem in a universe from uh uh '8s Oh. Oh. Oh, Dick.
Dick's already pissed. Dick's already pissed. Already misreading.
already misreading. Oh boy.
The first miss was Veto joining with his light off.